dans le cadre des journées européennes
du patrimoine qui auront lieu les samedi
17 et dimanche 18 septembre une
conférence de presse a eu lieu afin de
présenter les différents équipements
culturels qui participeront à
l'événement le département acteur majeur
de la protection et de la mise en valeur
du patrimoine mettra à disposition du
public huit de ses équipements culturels
département est un acteur majeur de la
protection de la mise en valeur du
patrimoine au service parce qu'il est
propriétaire d'une grande partie de ses
équipements et de ses sites de première
importance
ne pas oublier que le département depuis
la mise en place de ces journées
européennes du patrimoine est présent
aux côtés des institutions et acteurs
culturels ou pour participer à ces
événements
ces journées européennes sont
entièrement gratuites et c'est
l'occasion pour le public de venir
s'approprier son patrimoine de le
découvrir c'est entièrement gratuit
profitez-en venaient visiter en mémoire
les découvrir ou vous les re découvrir
ceux qui le connaissent tous ces si
absolument extraordinaire parmi les
différents équipements culturels que
possède le département le public sera
attendue au muséum d'histoire naturelle
au musée léon dierx alico knotek aux
archives départementales au musée du sel
au musée de villèle et à l'artothèque le
lazaret présent également ouvrira ses
portes au public dès le jeudi 15
septembre
alors pour ces journées européennes du
patrimoine nous proposons en partenariat
avec la confrérie des gens de la mer la
réhabilitation de la tombe du lieutenant
du lieutenant de vaisseau pardon hector
dubé dans le cimetière du lazaret numéro
un donc cette opération se déroulera
jeudi et vendredi à partir de 9h30
ensuite samedi
nous proposons deux conférences une
première conférence sur l'histoire du
chemin de fer à la réunion avec
l'association ti train une deuxième
conférence animée par michel marion
lotout obernai sur le choléra entre
maurice et la réunion
au 19e siècle nous avons également deux
autres partenariats d'un partenariat
avec le projet lie plus fort et sec ce
don qui propose proposera de
sensibiliser le public aux espèces
endémiques de la grande chaloupe avec
des ateliers de rempotage et à
partenariat avec le foyer médicalisé de
saint benoît est trop pop qui proposera
une exposition de photographies de
peintures sur le lazaret est une
manifestation qui permet à tous de
découvrir ou redécouvrir à travers ces
équipements culturels notre patrimoine
réunionnais